[Música]
el ex presidente estadounidense donald
trump volvió por primera vez a
washington desde el asalto al capitolio
y desde que salió de la casa blanca el
ex mandatario volvió a decir sin pruebas
que hubo fraude en las elecciones de
2020 que llevaron a joe biden a la
presidencia analizamos en esta emisión
en perú el ex secretario del presidente
pedro castillo bruno pacheco se entregó
a la justicia tras más de 100 días
prófugo es investigado por presunta
corrupción en un caso en el que también
estaría implicado el jefe de estado la
fiscal de la nación patricia benavides
afirmó que nada impedirá enfrentar a los
poderosos tenemos reporte desde lima
naciones unidas- alertó que 400 71
personas han muerto han resultado
heridas o han desaparecido en haití en
nueve días el organismo indicó que la
violencia se debe a una nueva oleada de
enfrentamientos entre bandas rivales que
operan en puerto príncipe la capital del
país
bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
eeuu el ex presidente de donald trump ha
arremetido contra su sucesor joe biden
en el primer mitin que celebra en
washington desde su salida del poder el
ex jefe del estado volvió a asegurar sin
pruebas que hubo fraude en las
elecciones de 2020 en las que vaivén
ganó la presidencia y resaltó la
necesidad de que los republicanos
recuperen el control en las elecciones
legislativas de medio mandato para
analizar esta noticia conectamos con
carlos escalante él es consultor
político internacional bienvenido a
france 24
con este tajante mensaje del ex
presidente de trump que se puede
interpretar hay sectores que creen en
sus palabras
sí ciertamente lo que está demostrado
valentina y de toda la audiencia es que
el gobierno del presidente vaya ha sido
tan tan malo en su gestión económica
fundamentalmente y el manejo de los
precios de inflación es que la campaña
se adelantó y ya el presidente de drones
prácticamente hoy anuncia desde
washington su lanzamiento cosas que ya
venía preparando el terreno de hacer
varias semanas él no sólo se lanza
también el presi el ex vicepresidente
pensé también estaba en washington
también anunciando su plan ya para
regresar a la casa blanca propia como
candidato presidencial y ciertamente el
presidente entró no ha perdido alguno de
su base pero va a ser un gran candidato
en la primaria a vencerme el principal
elemento a vencer en este en este evento
que va a ser y falta todavía mucho falta
la elección de medio término y nos queda
todavía llegar hasta el 24 pero esto lo
que demuestra este adelanto de
elecciones en la gestión del presidente
de bailén que ha sido bastante
equivocada el manejo económico bueno el
presidente de byd él le respondió en
twitter a trump es esto tradicional en
la política estadounidense que el
mandatario caiga en esta trampa de
responderle a un aspirante de un posible
aspirante a la presidencia
pero en el presente va el tam por
prácticamente está casi entrando en en
función como candidato presidencial lo
que él había dicho escribió a ser
candidato para el tema que está
anunciando que volvería a ser candidato
presidencial está jugando a la política
y ciertamente pelearse con bailén le
genera cierto apoyo dentro de las filas
demócratas realmente la situación
política de los liderazgos de ambos
demuestran una gran debilidad de ambos
partidos por lo los candidatos son dos
candidatos muy longevos y que
representan el continuismo pues señor
escalante a usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en france24
muchísimas gracias muy buenas noches en
otras noticias la inestabilidad política
aumenta con el pasar de las horas en
perú el ex secretario del presidente
pedro castillo bruno pacheco que llevaba
más de tres meses prófugo se entregó a
la justicia y permanecerá bajo custodia
el ex funcionario es investigado en un
caso por presunta corrupción en el que
supuestamente hubo irregularidades en la
licitación del puente tarata una hora
vial en la selvática región de san
martín en el mismo proceso estaría
involucrado el presidente castillo
francisco zacarías corresponsal de
france 24 nos dio detalles de lo que el
ex secretario presidencial está
declarando en la fiscalía fuentes de la
fiscalía revelan que bruno pacheco
durante su primer interrogatorio ha
confirmado que se realizaron pagos
ilícitos en los ascensos a generales de
la policía y una escolta del presidente
pedro castillo era el encargado de
recabar el dinero según versión de
pacheco el mandatario habría decidido
favorecer a diez coroneles de la policía
y a cada uno se le habría cobrado veinte
mil dólares pacheco también ha revelado
al ministerio público
en el parlamento existen 12 legisladores
de oposición quienes se encargan de
coordinar y proteger al mandatario el ex
secretario presidencial también le dijo
a la fiscalía que todo este tiempo se
mantuvo prófugo de la justicia peruana
por orden del presidente pedro castillo
en haití la guerra territorial entre
bandas sigue sembrando el terror en
puerto príncipe la capital naciones
unidas alertó que casi 500 personas han
muerto en resultado herida son
desaparecidos entre el 8 y el 17 de
julio desde hace más de 2 años las
organizaciones criminales gozan de una
impunidad generalizada por la crisis
política y la escasez de personal de la
policía los detalles con la aguja
más de 470 personas muertas heridas o
desaparecidas en 10 días el nuevo
informe de la onu alza la voz de alarma
sobre las consecuencias de los combates
entre bandas criminales en la cité
soleil además del balance humano las
conclusiones de la institución
internacional sobre las condiciones de
vida de la población son alarmantes
también se han denunciado graves
incidentes de violencia sexual contra
mujeres y niñas así como el
reclutamiento de niños por parte de las
bandas unas 3.000 personas han huido de
sus hogares entre ellas cientos de niños
no acompañados y al menos 140 casas han
sido destruidas o incendiadas frente a
esta violencia cada vez son más las
personas que intentan salir del país el
domingo 17 migrantes murieron y 25 más
fueron rescatados del naufragio de una
embarcación frente a las costas de
bahamas prácticamente todos eran
haitianos y para los que se quedan las
dificultades para acceder los productos
básicos se sumen al miedo de los
tiroteos cotidianos lo que les obliga a
veces a huir de sus casas y a buscar
refugio como esta escuela que acoge a
decenas de adultos y niños una bala
atravesó el techo y me dio en la cabeza
un sábado ese día ni hubo colegio nos
quedamos en casa muchas personas
murieron muchas personas fueron
disparadas y algunas no tuvieron la
oportunidad de salvarse las agencias
humanitarias comenzaron a prestar
asistencia a las personas más
vulnerables en cité soleil pero
denuncian un acceso limitado o
inexistente a los cuidados de salud y
piden a todas partes de comprometerse a
mantener un corredor humanitario abierto
hacia los civiles que necesitan una
ayuda de urgencia
vamos ahora a colombia porque el senado
recién posesionado el pasado 20 de julio
ratificó el acuerdo de escazú el primer
gran pacto ambiental de latinoamerica
falta la votación de la cámara de
representantes y la rúbrica presidencial
pese a que originalmente fue firmado por
24 países sólo dos se han ratificado el
pacto que además de proteger a los
ambientalistas busca una mejor
aplicación de políticas ecológicas así
como garantizar los derechos ambientales
y salvaguardar la biodiversidad
en panamá el presidente laurentino
cortizo hizo un llamado para superar la
crisis que vive el país tras las
protestas y bloqueos que continúan tras
más de tres semanas el mandatario pidió
diálogo urgente tras una reunión con
empresarios que solicitaron ser
incluidos junto con productores en la
mesa de conversaciones que se adelanta
entre el gobierno los gremios y los
sindicatos previamente oscar sulbarán
corresponsal de france 24 nos habló
sobre los avances en los diálogos
o la valentina como bien lo decías en la
tarde hoy el presidente de la republica
laurentino cortizo hizo una alocución al
país habló precisamente de parte de lo
que han significado estos avances en
cuanto al punto 1 que tenía que ver con
la reducción de la canasta básica en la
que se incluyeron entrerríos efectivos
artículos y también habló de su reunión
con los empresarios después
precisamente el sector privado había
manifestado su preocupación debido a
estas medidas que se estaban tomando en
la mesa de diálogo pues ellos
consideraban que iban a ser los
principales afectados y estaban
solicitando su inclusión en esa mesa y
algo en la locución el presidente
solicitó a su equipo coordinador en esta
mesa que hiciera las gestiones para que
el sector privado fuera incluido a esta
hora se ha iniciado hace pocos minutos
se ha iniciado la reunión de esa mesa de
diálogo donde ya se está tocando el
segundo punto que tiene que ver con el
aumento
combustible la reducción del precio del
combustible el gobierno lo ha fijado
entre 25 sin embargo los representantes
de estos gremios
que llevan adelante las protestas piden
que la reducción sea de 3 dólares el
galón
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]